bonjour bienvenue au parlement européen
à strasbourg pour un nouveau numéro d'
europe hebdo
au menu cette semaine le démantèlement
de la jungle de calais un quelques 9000
migrants et réfugiés répartis dans toute
la france des migrants qui veulent pour
la plupart rejoindre la grande bretagne
cette question faux faut-il renégocier
les accords du touquet avec les
britanniques
la crise migratoire pourrait-elle
remettre en cause le traité de 2003
entre la france et le royaume uni sur
les contrôles frontaliers la grande
bretagne toujours quatre mois après le
référendum sur la brique site où en
est-on le royaume uni donnera avant fin
mars 2017
le coup d'envoi officiel de sa sortie d'
union européenne c'est ce qu'a dit la
chef du gouvernement
theresa may concrètement le pays
signifiera alors qu'il déclenche
l'article 50 du traité de lisbonne 1 qui
prévoit le retrait volontaire et
unilatérale d'un état membre va-t-on
vers un break si dur c'est la question
qu'on se posera aujourd'hui avec nos
invités
les eurodéputés sylvie goulard et
philippe juvin mais d'abord le
démantèlement de la jungle de calais
depuis le début de la semaine les
migrants sont répartis dans différentes
communes de france de certains se sont
déjà installés soudanais ou afghans ils
s'intègrent souvent sous le regard
bienveillant parfois méfiant de la
population le reportage dans la vienne
de françois goulard
cette ancienne gendarmerie voie à la
destruction est désormais peuplé
d'habitants atypique 25 migrants que la
mairie de naintré a choisi d'accueillir
cet été en échange l'état paye une
association pour accompagner tous les
jours ces hommes soudanais et afghans
dans leur nouveau quotidien demande
d'asile droit s'est ému cours de
français et côté intégration
les habitants de naintré ont fait preuve
d'une certaine bienveillance au fur et à
mesure vous voyez les habitants qui
venait qui se présentait et ensuite eu
du coup ils sont arrivés plus ou moins
pendant le ramadan donc à la fin du
ramadan ils ont fait une fête où ils ont
invité tous les tous les voisins
maintenant il quand il joue à la
pétanque on allait voisin de derrière
qui viennent jouer avec eux quand ils
sont dehors ici on a ceux là qui
viennent leur dire bonjour
ouais ça a créé des liens pour israël ou
là qui a vécu dans la jungle de calais
ces petites attentions sont touchantes
ce jeune afghan aimerait s'installer ici
à naintré s'il obtient le statut de
réfugié n calais à calais c'est la loi
du plus fort
on vit comme des animaux les gens se bat
tout le temps ils agissent mal ici les
gens naintré sont très gentils les
associations nous aide on a une maison
le matin ont su des cours de français et
l'après midi on joue au football avec
les jeunes du village
c'est vraiment bien du voisinage plutôt
réceptifs émergent tout de même quelques
critiques
la france on va pas accueillir toute la
misère du monde donc il faut trouver des
solutions dans cette lignée de propos un
tel accueil doit nous coûter cher
s'inquiètent certains habitants faux
rétorque que la mère de naintré c'est un
enrichissement quelque part de la
collectivité à l'enrichissement parce
que ce bâtiment vide nous permet
maintenant de recevoir des loyers et
puis à la russie cement surtout humains
parce que ç'a permis au voisinage
d'avoir une autre approche des migrants
la mayonnaise a bien pris mais
l'alchimie ne fonctionne pas toujours
sur les 25 réfugiés accueillis à notre
et sept ont choisi de repartir vers
l'angleterre pour tenter leur chance
alors nous ont rejoints sur ce plateau
sylvie goulard bonjour vous êtes aux
députés centristes de l'alliance des
démocrates et libéraux pour l'europe
vous êtes une députée très assidus si au
parlement européen
en france vous avez été élu sous les
couleurs du modem merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation à côté de vous philippe
juvin bonjour je vous être député du
parti populaire européen en france vous
êtes un peu le monsieur europe chez les
républicains vous soutenez nicolas
sarkozy à la primaire de la droite et du
centre alors vous venez de voir le
reportage de françois goulard
ça se passe plutôt bien la répartition
d'immigrants et quand ça se fait par par
petits groupes
6000 à 8000 migrants à répartir et on
fait tout un pataquès en france alors
que la grèce et l'italie sont confrontés
à des milliers de réfugiés qu'est ce qui
se passe en france
sylvie goulard non je crois que la
réaction de la population n'est pas
étonnante il faut entendre les gens
cette idée qu'on pourrait accueillir des
personnes de tous les pays du monde où
il ya des difficultés je comprends que
ces angoisses les gens d'un autre côté
effectivement comme vous venez de le
dire il faut bien voir que la france
jusqu'à présent ne prend pas une part
extrêmement lourde du fardeau en europe
puisqu'il ya eu plus d'un million de
personnes accueillies en allemagne et
qu'il y a notamment en grèce et en
italie une arrivée encore aujourd'hui de
personnes qui notamment en italie sont
souvent sauvés en mer avec des
conditions très difficiles
donc on a besoin d'une politique
européenne qui bien sûr aura un volet
diplomatique ou militaire afin d'essayer
de stabiliser l'environnement européen
mais aussi une action humanitaire est ce
que ce reportage je crois montre c'est
que plus les unités son petit et des
liens humains peuvent se créer
et plus on a de chances que ça se passe
relativement bien est-ce que
l'évacuation philippe 27 semaines
changera quelque chose allait à la
situation puisque ça dure depuis 20 ans
non mais en réalité ça ne m'a rien
changé on a aucune façon résolue la
question de la jungle de calais on a en
fait diluer le problème on a déplacé des
tous ces 10000 malheureuse à leurs gens
qui vivaient dans des conditions
épouvantables et finalement on les a
déplacés mais on n'a pas réglé le
problème
nous nous pensons qu'à partir du moment
où un certain nombre d'entre eux une
grande majorité veulent passer au
royaume uni et bien qu'ils passent au
royaume-uni et que le royaume uni gère
ces demandes d'asile les britanniques
ont voulu sortir de l'union européenne
on va en parler
écoutez maintenant c'est leur affaire je
le regrette moi je pense que leur place
était dans l'union européenne pour les
frontières on est à gaza à partir du
moment où les britanniques veulent
sortir d assumer les conséquences de
leurs choix et de leurs frontières
un des grands éléments d'un débat du
break 6 était nous allons reprendre le
contrôle de nos frontières c'est ce qui
nous racontait partout
et bien maintenant chiche qui reprennent
le contrôle de leurs frontières et puis
qu'ils accueillent
c'est malheureux et traitent chacun des
dossiers et qu'il juge si oui ou non
qu'ils peuvent faire l'objet d'asile
mais si vous voulez il ya une grande
hypocrisie des britanniques dans cette
affaire qui dit aller français j'ai
régis raynaud désole la france est
généreuse et l'angleterre de l'âge elle
se trouvera toujours au même endroit
avec son marché du travail très libérale
à vous savez ça c'est sable en
angleterre de travailler même quand on
est cordes et stables entre pas de
papiers d'identité
est-ce que ce que le problème ne se
reposera pas à pas un jour à jour l'os
et les goula il est évident que les
accords du touquet qui ont été signés il
ya maintenant quelques années que je
rappelle à 2003 conclue en février 2003
entre londres et paris avec nicolas
sarkozy à la signature ans ministre de
l'intérieur et ça n'a rien à voir avec
l'appartenance à l'union
donc la question juridique c est ce qu
on maintient ils ont déplacé côté
français contrôle de la firme
britannique le royaume y va rester une
île je crois qu'il faut pas se faire
d'illusions il y aura de façon des gens
qui arrivent à calais mais là où je
je ne résiste pas si j'ose dire discuter
avec les italiens sur ce qui se passe à
28 les français essayent aussi
d'empêcher des réfugiés ou d'immigrants
de franchir la frontière entre l'italie
et la france donc soit on se repasse
systématiquement le mistigri soit on
essaye d'avoir une attitude un peu plus
raisonnable moi je tiens à dire une
chose je suis très frappé de voir que
beaucoup de partis qui insiste sur la
nation le caractère national trouve
anormal que l'effort soit réparti entre
les différentes régions françaises
ça n'est pas seulement le problème de la
ville de calais moi je passe pas mon
temps chanté la marseillaise et agité
des drapeaux bleu blanc rouge sur les
estrades
mais ceux qui le font on devrait
peut-être se demander si je n'ai pas de
leçon à recevoir en la matière non mais
ce que je veux dire c'est le contraste
entre les gens qui ainsi sur des
responsabilités nationales et le refus
de considérer que c'est une question qui
concerne l'ensemble du pays et
l'ensemble du pays dans son rapport au
royaume uni et au reste de l'union
européenne ont refusé la répartition si
en fait se défausser sur les gens qui
sont dans le nord de la france non moi
je ne dis pas ça je dis que prétendre
qu'on a réglé la question de calais en
diluant le problème et en déplaçant ces
malheureux partout en france
c'est faux on n'a rien réglé du tout il
faut renégocier les accords du tout
qu'il faut évidemment renégocier les
accords du coup touquet qui date d'une
période où ne connaissions pas cette
situation je vous rappelle que à calais
y avait mille personnes il ya une
dizaine d'années il ya onze mille
personnes dix fois plus deuxièmement
c'est certain c'est ça le problème c'est
certes un accord intergouvernemental
entre le royaume uni et la france et
sept
ce n'est pas une question
institutionnellement une question
européenne les accords du gatt il est
vrai mais ne reste pas moins que les
conditions politiques ont changé et le
regard que nous avons nous français
vis-à-vis des britanniques
aujourd'hui n'est pas le même après le
président ils veulent leur indépendance
qu'ils apprennent et qu'ils assument
leurs frontières puisqu'il paraît que
c'était la solution miracle justement
vous parlez du break site à la sortie du
royaume uni de l'union européenne on a
dit que cela devait aller vite là on se
retrouve avec theresa may a le premier
ministre britannique qui dit qu'on ne
déclenchera pas l'article saint-quentin
l'ouverture des négociations avant fin
mars 2010 est elle aura alors deux
pour boucler leur exit une éternité pour
certains quid des 72 députés
britanniques qui siège toujours ici au
parlement européen comment ces
parlementaires vivent cette situation
inédite à ils sont là mais pas tout à
fait là on fait avec
même si on sent une perte d'influencé le
reportage de brice lambert
sa mixtape wall street view
au lendemain du breakbeat jean claude
juncker interpellait le britannique
nigel farrage leader de la campagne pour
la sortie du royaume uni quatre mois
plus tard les 72 députés britanniques
sont toujours bien en place au parlement
david coburn et membre du lieu keep un
parti populiste qui a fait campagne pour
la sortie de l'union européenne
en attendant il entend bien profiter
encore un peu les avantages offerts par
sa fonction les députés ont le droit de
passer devant tout le monde et ça c'est
très intéressante et comme nombre de ses
collègues propres exit david coburn n'a
pas beaucoup apprécié les propos de
jean-claude juncker nous resterons
membres de cette option tant que nous
participerons au budget et d'ailleurs
nous payons plus d'argent que ce pays le
luxembourg
alors qu'est ce qu'il fait c'est notre
argent s'il n'en veux qu'à qu ils nous
le rendent avec plus de 14 milliards
d'euros
le royaume uni est le quatrième plus
gros contributeurs du budget de l'union
pas question pour david coburn de
relâcher la vigilance budgétaire surtout
avec le brésil
nous avons toujours veillé à défendre
les intérêts britanniques et surtout à
vérifier que notre argent est bien
dépensé
nous allons continuer à être très
attentifs mais ce qu'il y a de nouveau
pour nous c'est que nous allons
maintenant devoir son déminer le terrain
déjouez les pièges que l'union
européenne veut nous tendre dans les
négociations du break site
2019 sera la date probable de la sortie
du royaume uni d'ici là les députés
britanniques travailler comme d'habitude
ils siègent dans les commissions en
préside toujours 3 et participent au
vote le député travailliste richard
corbett et membre de la commission des
affaires constitutionnelles
il reconnaît que l'ambiance n'est plus
tout à fait la même
le semble toujours là jusqu'au dernier
jour ne sont membres du parlement
européen
sur un autre plan politique et
émotionnel bien sûr il ya des choses qui
ont changé c'est s'il ya un membre du
club qui va quitter le club il a
évidemment peut-être moins d'affluence
il est peut-être un peu mal vu par les
autres
pour la présidente de sa commission il
n'y a aucune raison d'écarter le député
britannique
bien au contraire ils abritent chaque
corbeille
nous continuons à travailler avec
richard corbett qui est un ami de
l'europe
il sera bientôt nommé rapporteur sur le
règlement du parlement européen pour les
dix prochaines années et nous avons
totalement confiance en ses compétences
du côté des conservateurs le discours
est sensiblement le même
richard ashworth et député européen
depuis 2004 lui aussi entend continuer à
exercer pleinement son mandat
le royaume uni va probablement quitter
l'europe en 2010 alors bien sûr les
députés britanniques ne seront pas
consulté sur les textes qui auront des
implications au delà de cette date
mais en attendant nous sommes membre de
plein droit et donc nous sommes engagés
au parlement et dans le travail en
commissions continuer à avancer sans
vraiment connaître le cap même pour
graham watson un vétéran des
institutions bruxelloises les conditions
de sortie des britanniques sont encore
totalement incertaine
nous sommes dans le flou on ne sait pas
s'il y aura ou cook est on fera avec les
sièges vacants au parlement européen on
envisage une europe sans la grande
bretagne
mais les britanniques de même sambre ne
pas savoir vraiment ce qu'ils veulent
officiellement les négociations pour la
sortie du royaume-uni devrait démarrer
au mois de mars prochain
le début d'une discussion qui devrait
durer au moins deux ans
voilà un reportage de brice lambert ils
sont dans une situation assez inédite à
nos eurodéputés britanniques qui vous le
dise
sylvie goulard oui il ya une différence
entre le droit et la situation
matérielle le droit le votre reportage
le montre bien pour l'instant ils sont
députés jusqu'à la fin je pense quand
même qu'on doit pouvoir aussi trouvé une
sorte on va appeler un anglicisme and
gentleman agreement avec eux pour éviter
qu'ils soient rapporteur de textes
importants pour éviter qu'ils aient des
amendements qui fasse basculer
moi je suis en commission des affaires
économiques et monétaires où nous avons
des textes concernant la finance et qui
impacte tout particulièrement la city et
le travail des banques ou des marchés au
royaume uni il n'est pas envisageable
même si juridiquement c'est
théoriquement possible que nos collègues
et jeudi à certains d'entre eux que je
respecte continuent à impacter la
législation d'un autre côté on peut pas
les chasser voyez il faut trouver
quelque chose qui soit je dirais un
arrangement pragmatique on envisage une
europe sans la grande bretagne mais les
britanniques eux mêmes semblent ne pas
savoir ce qu'ils veulent c'est ce que 10
heures graham watson il a pas tort le
jeu va écouter informellement les
britanniques ont malheureusement voter
pour le président donc les britanniques
ont dit ce qu'ils voulaient même si
manifestement certains ont été trompés
par une propagande qui étaient
mensongères on se souvient du fameux
débat sur des centaines de millions de
livres qui reviendrait à la grande
bretagne pour le système de santé le
jour où il sortirait et cet argument de
campagne a été finalement avoué comme
étant un mensonge par les tenants du
brésil le lendemain dans le vrai sujet
c'est que comme le dit sylvie goulard
fort justement juridiquement ils sont
membres
mais moi je bouillais en regardant votre
reportage
parce que au moins les députés qui ont
plaidé la sortie de l'europe
au moins cela aurait dû avoir un sursaut
d'honneur et démissionner le lendemain
du bric site
rien ne les oblige bien entendu mais
enfin l'honneur c'est quand même quelque
chose et là ils vous expliquent ah non
non non c'est bien en plus on peut ne
pas faire la queue à la q à la buvette
des députés c'est formidable à soupe est
bonne c'est honteux alors que les
collègues britanniques qui
rester dans l'europe continue à
travailler certes même si c'est bien
ennuyeux moi ma présidente de la
commission dans la commission du marché
intérieur et une britannique-- c'est
elle qui mène les débats quand on nous
sommes en négociations dans ce qu'on
appelle les trilogue avec la commission
quand même c'était un petit sujet mais
quand à ceux qui ont demandé plaidé qu
on sorte qu'il sorte de l'union ah bon
sens qui démissionne c'est la moindre
des choses ça il ya un cynisme qui n'est
pas seul aux pieds pas propre aux
britanniques moi je suis choqué depuis
longtemps et d'ailleurs j'ai fait des
amendements pour proposer qu'on ne
puisse pas être membre du parlement
européen si on veut la destruction de
l'europe imaginez à l'assemblée
nationale des gens qui n'ont pas
défendre et des thèses politiques de
nouri voudrait votre et la destruction
de la république et la destruction de la
france
au bout d'un moment les contribuables se
dirait mais pourquoi on les paye
l'europe a été trop bonne fille
vis-à-vis de tous ces gens nous
entretenons ici c'est quoi les
souverainistes les eurodéputés soient
nationales veulent détruire le système
c'est leur responsabilité ils n'ont pas
besoin
si j'étais à leur place j'aurais un peu
du mal à me regarder dans la glace le
matin et imaginer que je suis payé que
mes collaborateurs sont payés par une
institution que je veux détruire et ça
il ya des gens que ça choquera peut-être
que je dise ça mais je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de monde
faut faire la différence entre la
destruction du système et la volonté le
faire évoluer en france encore une fois
je répète des amis radicaux de la
république
je ne suis pas sûr oui mais je ne suis
pas sûr qu'on en tolérerait autant et
donc on a là à mon avis les conséquences
d'une situation qu'on a toléré laisser
prospérer et qui finit par se retourner
parce que c'est facile de dire le break
site va être dur etc
mais nous avons aussi des intérêts dans
cette affaire nous avons des
ressortissants qui vivent au royaume uni
nous avons des banques qui sont
installés là-bas nous avons des
entreprises qui ont investi donc à la
fois je suis pour ma part pour des
solutions fermes mais ne nous faisons
pas d'illusions nous sommes aussi
entraînés dans des négociations dans
lesquelles nous serons bien obligés nous
aussi de faire des concessions alors
gouvernement conservateur britannique
n'est pas encore ce qu'il veut il doit
décider s'il veut rester dans le marché
unique s'il veut autoriser la libre
circulation des personnes ou limiter
l'immigration
mais la réalité c'est que les
britanniques ont voté pour le break site
en dix ans après c'était le paradis
enfin certains
et voyant les difficultés de la chose
font tout pour reculer l'échéance
il n'a échappé à personne que les
britanniques gagnent du temps et raconte
que demain on a un calendrier
par donna sorte la sortie serait
effective en 2009 il est vrai qu'on
commence à avoir un calendrier qui est
le suivant et c'est tout c'est que au
printemps la première ministre va
déposer un projet de loi devant le
parlement britannique mais projet de loi
il va être amendé discuter il pourra
être refusée ont donc le 2019 dont tout
le monde il est certain jonah hill est
pas du tout certains cas quand même pas
pour les téléspectateurs c'est important
de le souligner enfin je partage cette
cet analyste il ya beaucoup
d'incertitudes mais 2019 c'est la date
des prochaines élections européennes et
du renouvellement de la commission
européenne je pense qu'il est légitime
et je dirais que l'issue dépend aussi
des partenaires du royaume uni de la
france et d'autre de dire clairement
qu'il est hors de question d'organiser
des élections européennes avec un pays
qui seraient en train de négocier sa
sortie dont il faut clarifier l'idée que
c'est fini pour la présence dans les
institutions même si peut-être certaines
négociations continueront ou des
périodes transitoires devront être
inventés pour les britanniques ils ont
l'objectif de l'accès au marché unique 1
sans respecter les normes européennes et
sans respecter la libre circulation ça
c'est la ligne britannique c'est
possible on peut accepter ça non non non
il n'est pas question dans ces cas là je
sais la fin de l'europe
chacun prendra ce qui l'intéresse non il
ya un tout c'est que les biens les
marchandises les services les personnes
des capitaux circulent librement
mais c'est un tout c'est pas un petit
peu et il ya un autre sujet qui est très
français là et qui nous intéresse a
clairement été très continental
c'est ce sont toutes ces entreprises
britanniques ou européennes d'ailleurs
installé à londres et qui bénéficient de
ce qu'on appelle le passeport européen
sylvie goulard se connaissent à parker
et ses entreprises ont besoin
en fait de ce passeport européen qui est
à l'autorisation de travailler avec
l'union européenne dans le cadre du
marché unique est ce que ce qu'il faut
c'est que la france se met dans les
conditions d'accueillir ces entreprises
qui vont devoir choisir un autre site
vont elles allaient à francfort vont à
l'aller à dublin
vont elles aller à paris et mon
inquiétude c'est va-t-on tirer les
marrons du feu
nous français un peu égoïstement pardon
de du fait que les entreprises vont
quitter le royaume sur le président
proprement dit on on se dirigerait donc
vers exit dur ça veut dire quoi c'est le
vilain non ces mots là sont vides de
sens et pour ma part je nuancerais un
tout petit peu ce que philippe juvin
viens de dire
il est vrai qu'il ya une bataille
affaire qui est de ne pas permettre à
des entreprises notamment de pays tiers
par exemple des banques américaines ou
chinoises installées à londres de
continuer à être active sur le continent
sans avoir mis des capitaux des
garanties sans se soumettre à nos
contrôles au départ de londres
mais je ne crois pas un instant qu'ils
soient si facile que ça de transférer
cette espèce d'écosystèmes qu'est la
city de londres qui la première place
financière du monde si on essaie et moi
j'ai vu la campagne je pris l'eurostar
la semaine dernière pour aller à lons
les campagnes qui consiste à dire si
vous aimez pas le brouillard essayé la
france avec un jeu de mots sur forgan
frog c'est bien gentil mais ça n'a rien
à voir avec l'ampleur de la difficulté
la chose que nous observons en ce moment
même je comprends que les choses sont
toujours plus complexe que sur un
plateau de télévision
il n'empêche pas moins qu'il faut que
nous donnions un signal très fort aux
entreprises britanniques ou installé à
londres plus exactement quelles sont les
bienvenus à paris parce que si nous ne
donnons pas signalé ne viendront jamais
oui mais ça dépend d'un environnement
fiscal social et d'une image du pays je
dirais très sincèrement que la querelle
qu'il ya en ce moment entre les partis
français sur l'accueil des migrants et
des réfugiés
on voit de toute façon une image
objectivement et malheureusement
tellement négative que c'est un peu
facile encore une fois pour revenir au
coeur du problème
le coeur du problème c'est la
souveraineté de la zone euro c'est la
question de savoir si les transactions
en euros se feront dans la zone euro ou
à new york parce qu'une des hypothèses
les plus vraisemblable c'est que si
certaines entreprises quittent londres
elles iront probablement soit aux états
unis soit hong kong la finance et
globalisé c'est un des vrais on a
intérêt à jouer une carte de l'unité
laisse que l'intérêt de l'union
européenne ce n'est pas aussi d'avoir à
bréxent il durera pour qu'on puisse voir
les conséquences d'une sortie de l'union
européenne pour faire peur l'intérêt
d'une aux états unis seraient tentés de
sortir l'intérêt du droit au ras avant
tout cette machine d'intérêt la première
chose c'est de défendre ses intérêts
l'union doit se considérer comme une
puissance si elle se considère vraiment
comme une puissance que nous souhaitons
tous elle affirmera ses intérêts y
compris face aux britanniques
c'est ça le sujet il s'agit pas de punir
la question n'est pas là c'est quels
sont les intérêts des européens face à
des prêts technique qui disent on sort
alors maintenant il est certain que si
nous sommes faibles
nous ne défendons pas nos intérêts en
plus nous donnerons un mauvais signal
qui consisterait à dire au fond on peut
faire n'importe quoi en europe et
l'europe ça devient un supermarché ou
avec mon caddie je prends ce qui
m'intéresse et effectivement les
polonais les machins les trucs oui mais
parce que moi si on regarde ce qui est
au coeur du projet européen
c'est l'acceptation de règles communes
et d'un respect des règles sous l'égide
d'institutions notamment la cour de
justice dont madame même veut se
débarrasser ce qui en partie je dirais
et règle la difficulté c'est pas nous
qui voulons un mexique du rhône où les
britanniques pose des conditions qui
font qu'ils sont en train de s'exclure
totalement du système mais j'ai tendance
à penser aussi que quand la france sur
tous les gouvernements successifs n'a
pas respecté les règles par exemple
budgétaire européenne
elle ne s'est pas non plus comporté
d'une manière telle qu'elle doit donner
des leçons aux autres ou faire croire
que c'est toujours les autres qui
doivent respecter les règles terrible
vraiment si cette autoflagellation
nationale s'est passé là sûr j'ai pas
parlé de ça du budget national je dis
simplement qu'il faut que les principes
que nous affichions ne serait ce que
pour qu'ils soient crédibles y compris
que les britanniques nous renvoie pas
des contrats ou alors la figure
il faut que nous le respections et il
faut que nous expliquions
téléspectateurs c'est surtout pour ça
que nous sommes beaucoup plus forts
ensemble ce qui veut dire qu'il faut que
tous les acteurs dans tous les domaines
c'est pas de la sphère
l'autoflagellation c'est la défense de
la solidité du système européen
si tout le monde y travaillent et y a
pas des petits jeux de sape les uns
contre les autres parce que moi je veux
récupérer un bout du gâteau à ce
moment-là ça marchera mieux dans cette
négociation là qui s'engagent sur le
break site quel sera le rôle du
parlement européen
on sait qu'ils verhofstadt a été nommé
pour négocier pour représenter le
parlement européen michel barnier pour
représenter la commission et monsieur
ces housses pour prendre représenter le
conseil
mais quel sera le rôle du parlement
européen des eurodéputés et d'avoir le
vote final
moi je pense qu'effectivement il ya le
rôle du vote final certes et puis il ya
tout ce rôle comment dirais-je
intellectuelle qui consiste à
a affirmé que l'europe n'est pas
divisible en petits morceaux inégaux et
que l'europe est un intérêt commun c'est
à dire que nous pensons et nous le
dirons et nous le répéterons que nos
nations respectives
quelle que soit leur histoire quelles
que soient leurs richesses qu'elle vous
soit leur patrimoine ne pèseront dans
les affaires du monde demain que si
elles sont unies et c'est ça que le
parlement va collectivement dire et
affirmer et moi je me résous je me
réjouis absolument de la nomination de
verhofstadt comme négociateurs du
parlement
c'est un européen convaincu mais plus
encore c'est quelqu'un qui est à
l'opposé de la naïveté qu'on reproche
parfois européen très clairement pour
les téléspectateurs le traité prévoit
donc une négociation où les états donne
mandat à la commission michel barnier
fera ça très bien pour la commission il
ya un contrôle à la fin du parlement
mais vous imaginez bien que sur un acte
aussi complexe le parlement va pas se
contenter à la fin de donner un coup de
tampon sur un accord dont on n'aurait
pas entendu parler donc il faut
accompagner le processus est comme ça a
été dit par philippe juin la compagnie
aussi vis-à-vis de l'opinion publique
expliquait pourquoi nous défendons le
maintien du système parce que le système
tel qu'il est ce système de droit permet
à un citoyen permet à une entreprise qui
s'estiment lésés dans la concurrence
européenne par exemple de défendre ses
droits c'est ça que nous voulons
défendre des libertés défendre des
droits
donc il ya quelque chose de plus que la
défense d'un système parce que nous en
ferions la dernière question à nicolas
sarkozy propose que le royaume uni
votent à nouveau sur le pré ce site ça
vous inspire quoi c'est possible à bien
le break c'était irréversible
effectivement il propose ça mais il ya
une petite explication à voir avant
parce que sinon on ne comprend pas bien
ce que nous pensons nous c'est que il y
a un problème de gouvernance européenne
et de bon fonctionnement des
institutions et donc nous pensons il dit
si j'aimerais avoir un jury du président
avoir une job de bergeret sur un nouveau
traité ce que nous souhaitons sur les
britanniques votent ce que nous
souhaitons c'est un nouveau traité un
nouvel accord avec l'allemagne en
particulier un nouveau couple
franco-allemand et à partir du moment où
nous aurions négocier de nouvelles
règles de fonctionnement de l'union
européenne
là pour le coup peut-être c'est une
manière de rattraper les britanniques en
leur disant regardez le rapidement vous
en voulez mais nous l'avons nous allons
la faire évoluer break 6 et
irréversibles subis groupe démocrate et
dont
je pense que pour l'instant nous avons
un message clair du peuple britannique
après il ya aussi des considérations
constitutionnelles interne du royaume
uni le parlement de westminster où le
peuple britannique sera amenés à valider
l'accord ça c'est évident ça se fait
toujours comme ça la ratification d'un
accord est autorisé par le parlement ou
par le peuple
je ne crois pas trop à ce scénario et
j'y vois un danger majeur philippe un
danger majeur c'est que si on renégocie
sans les britanniques ils accepteront
jamais et si on les a introduits dans la
renégociation d'un nouveau traité à ce
moment-là demanderont encore une fois un
statut spécial très très rapide moi je
vois danger banneux un danger majeur à
ne pas renégocier les traités
c'est tout simplement la disparition
apoptose vite pour sauver l'europe il
faut là rené aussi l'espace si vous
mettez le royaume uni dans la
renégociation
et si vous les imiter on aura le même
genre de faiblesses auxquelles on a
assisté par le passé c'est à dire la
tentation de donner un statut ce sera je
ne crois pas ce sera le mot de la fin en
tout cas merci avoue sylvie goulard
d'avoir accepté notre invitation merci à
vous philippe juvin d'être venus
débattre je sais que vous êtes beaucoup
sollicités en ce moment en ce moment la
campagne des primaires à droite oblige
vous êtes dans le camp de nicolas
sarkozy
beaucoup de meetings merci à vous de
nous avoir suivis c'est la fin de leur
peine de rester avec nous sur les
chaînes parlementaires bail